und wir schauen auf verstörende bilder
den zwei schlägern in einem supermarkt
die auf zwei polizisten eingedroschen
haben sie schwer verletzt haben
sie sollen jetzt aus politischen motiven
gehandelt haben wir haben hier bei bild
darüber berichtet der staatsschutz hat
die ermittlungen aufgenommen und die
bonner polizei teilt bildmitte dass
einer der beiden früher bereits in
ermittlung mit dem bezug zur reichs
bürgern aufgefallen sei deren anhänger
lehnen unter anderem die rechtsordnung
der bundesrepublik ab und das kann ein
hinweis darauf sein warum die beiden in
den laden ohne maske rhein sind und dann
die polizisten hart attackiert haben
unser kollege frank schneider ist vor
ort wo gerade eine razzia in diesem fall
durchgeführt wird in bonn ging einen
dieser mutmaßlichen täter selbst gefilmt
selbst dieses video ins netz gestellt
franke diese razzia welchen hintergrund
hat sie was erhoffen sich die polizisten
zu finden
ja ich sehe erst mal sagen das war ein
bisschen hektisch man kann irgendwann so
fahrzeug hier geht auch gerade ein
beamter den job kosten enthält
wahrscheinlich in der richtung wir gehen
einfach mal ein stück weiter kommt mit
hier stehen auch noch kollegen das ist
dieses haus um das es geht ist die
polizei über waffen unterstützt
eingegangen man suche nach dem mann
jetzt offenbar aber nicht angetroffen
der anwalt hat erst begonnen da bieten
vielleicht auch im hinterkopf
dabei sind die beamten gerade unter ob
sie spuren finden sie öffnen
man sieht es hier hinten im hintergrund
dort sind wieder und geschützte beamte
die dort hinten stehen ist natürlich der
einsatz
hintergrund ist natürlich das im
supermarkt dieser übergriff die polizei
warnt stattgefunden hat aber das
entscheiden die polizei hinweise darauf
dass die beiden das ganz bewusst ganz
provokativ gemacht haben dass sie das
zukünftig auch weiter machen wollen und
zwar wollen sie weiter den polizisten
provozieren wollen sie vor der kamera
sozusagen auseinandersetzung locken und
wo das weitermachen da hat die polizei
hinweise tropfen ist deshalb heute hier
nochmal mit massiven aufgebot
entschieden die beiden sondern auch
mitgenommen werden wenn sie denn
angetroffen haben andere objekte sind in
ihren bann
doch das gibt es eine weitere
durchsuchung dort geht es um details und
die bitten der mann stand der gefilmt
hat und wie gesagt dort gibt es einen
weiteren einsatz
und man muss abwarten ob sie beide jetzt
braucht angst und festgenommen werden
können stellt sich dann natürlich die
frage kurz nach dem vorfall hat man die
beiden jahr erkennungsdienstlich
behandelt und alles aufgenommen hat sie
dann wieder freigelassen warum denn dann
jetzt diese razzia mit der erhofften
festsetzung der beiden mutmaßlichen
täter man muss da unterscheiden es gibt
natürlich nicht darum dass es ein ein
haftbefehl gegen soll sondern es geht
darum dass man die beiden einfach jetzt
erkennungsdienst dich noch mal behandeln
will man will natürlich ich möchte mal
recht können wieder beamten filmhaus in
der eingangstür geht jetzt wieder rein
angetroffen ich komme mal auf deine
frage zurück in der punkt bei der
geschichte ist dass die beiden eben im
supermarkt angezettelt haben aber
daneben hinweise entstanden sind dass
sie im netz gepostet haben das machen
wir jetzt regelmäßig wir den immer
wieder polizisten provozieren wir werden
sie in auseinandersetzungen verwickelt
und man hat ja auch einen zettel
das kann man in dem video aussehen hat
einen zettel an die polizisten übergeben
und dar und steht er wird immer
widerstand leisten
obergoms dieser heißt die ja deutschland
nicht anerkennt eine deutschland gmbh
hier hintergrund immer sagt wir sind
noch mehr oder weniger zu zeigen das
kaiserreich ist deutschland ablehnen
keine ausweise tragen will keine
ausweise haben will und vor diesem
hintergrund bild sei jetzt bewusst
provozieren und da sagt die polizei
nicht mit uns wir gehen jetzt gegen die
vor dass sind andere straftaten das sind
planung weiterer straftaten und das ist
auch der grund warum man jetzt hier
einen durchsuchungsbeschluss bekommen
hat von einem amtsrichter und jetzt
diese wohnung durchsucht nach
beweismitteln nach möglichen weiteren
geplanten straftaten und will die beiden
dann erstmal festsetzen ein haftbefehl
existiert momentan ist unser
kenntnisstand nicht aber man will sie
erst mal mitnehmen vernehmen unter
fragen was sie vorhaben und dann hat die
polizei noch vor eine sogenannte
gefährderansprache zu machen den nämlich
zu sagen wir wissen genau was hier vorab
lasst es sein sonst gibt es nämlich dann
wegen möglicher wiederholungsgefahr
vielleicht irgendwann doch den
haftbefehlen muss die polizei vorsichtig
sein bei der handhabung dieser reichs
bürger denn in vergangenheit in der
vergangenheit gab es schon
beispielsweise razzien oder
durchsuchungen gab es auch schusswechsel
mit der polizei mit opfern
da bei den beamten wie geht die polizei
jetzt bei dir vor mit größter vorsicht
nämlich ja völlig richtig dass du sagst
da hatten ja den schrecklichen vorfall
zu beklagen
2016 in sachsen-anhalt dabei ist ein sek
beamter erschossen worden
deswegen ist die polizei hier auch mit
massiven einsatzkräften vor ort wie
gesagt da gestützt mit zusätzlichen
schutz besten mit hätten mit
schutzschild ist man rein gegangen mit
einer ramme weil man genau das eben
immer so richten muss man wissen hat
häufig auch zugang zu waffen das ein
ganz großes problem für die beamten man
weiß auch nie wer hat wie zugang zu
waffen und vor diesem hintergrund geht
man eben ganz ganz vorsichtig vor und
eben ganz geschützt weil man nie
ausschließen kann dass australien dieser
leute immer massiver widerstand
geleistet wir haben sie im supermarkt
gesehen und wie gesagt sie drohungen im
internet dort straftaten weitere
widerstände gegen polizeibeamten und
deswegen geht man hier sehr vorsichtig
vor und ist wie gesagt mit sehr
martialisch im aufgebot ins haus
gestürmt ist jetzt gerade mal knapp zehn
minuten her